it's been 16 years since the first
psychonauts
game but on august 25th we're finally
getting a sequel to the cult classic
that's a lot to live up to
and thankfully from five hours of
hands-on time with the preview version
of the game
i can tell you this that it is
bolstering
with double fine's signature creativity
while also
tackling some pretty serious topics of
mental health
with more intentionality than the first
one ever did
the result is as ambitious as it is
inspiring
so let's get into it the story picks up
only hours after the first game in
moments after the vr sequel interlude
psychonauts and the rhombus of ruin
10 year old psychic prodigy rest spun
has saved the leader of the psychonauts
truman
zenato with the help of fellow
psychonaut agents from the grips
of the maniacal dentist amateur brain
surgeon
dr lobato let's check out those
choppers the first level kicks off with
you entering the mind of dr lobato to
find out who hired him to kidnap truman
all you need to do is get this vacation
request
approved by your supervisor what
once lovato becomes aware there's agents
inside of his head his dental background
starts to protrude through the office
walls
quite literally and it's eerie as it is
inspiring that's gross the level
equally acts as a tutorial teaching
players how to maneuver with double
jumps wall jumping as well as briefing
on returning abilities that players from
the original will
be pretty familiar with however with a
lot of quality of life improvements that
make them a whole lot
better telekinesis for example now
operates more like the game control so
items nearby will automatically come to
you
making it easy to launch it at an enemy
pyrokinesis forms an area of attack
bubble to better visualize its execution
and cyblast has a cooldown rather than
having to collect
aggression ammo all of these
improvements actually made this one feel
more actiony than the first one which is
a good thing because
in this case it felt tight it feels
refined especially
with the addition of a dodge button
through lobato's mine i encountered
mainstay enemies from the first game
like the sensors
but also an array of new enemies like
regrets flying creatures that carry
heavy weights to drop on you
now one of the most effective ways to
kill these buggers because they're
flying
is by using the long range ability
cyblast
the moment i did that i was able to pick
up one of its weights and launch it
right into a sensor
and it was very very satisfying
with the introduction of each new enemy
i was conditioned to change my playing
style often switching out abilities to
control the onslaught
new enemies like doubt sludge-like
creatures that can slow you down
are highly flammable so pyrokinesis came
in clutch while enablers support enemies
that make foes invincible
were fast and agile requiring the use of
time bubble
a new ability that temporarily slows an
enemy in place giving me the chance to
lay in on the beatdown
the constant introduction of different
enemy types learning their weaknesses
and understanding the abilities on hand
offered consistent variety with multiple
methods to tackle the situation
most impressive is double fine's
interlacing of conceptual design with
its enemies like using feelings of
regret
doubt and enabling as literal
interpretations for enemy types
but like the first game it's not all
about the action but moments of
exploration
too in psychonauts 2 the psychonauts
headquarters known as the motherlobe
is akin to the whispering rock sidekick
summer camp from the first game
a wide and open connective hub-like area
upon entering the hq you're greeted with
a towering mural of the organization's
leaders known as the psychic six
the room is alive with agents talking to
each other bustling around
reading books or having lunch you can
hear the thoughts of some agents while
others use their abilities to tend to
watering plants or
levitate to other platforms hi i'm sorry
i just hate children a brain in a
hamster ball is rolling around
sorry there's a rat and a leather jacket
and voices reverberate from the pa
system this area is also the
introduction to many new
characters of psychonauts 2 including
hollis forsythe the no-nonsense
second head of psychonauts and now rez's
new teacher
and because this is psychonauts when raz
goes to class he actually enters the
minds of his
teachers and it's during this moment
when you enter hollis mind
that the game starts to show the depth
of his characterization
when raz is in there he learns the
ability mental connection which can be
used to interconnect a person's thoughts
or
even completely change their mind when
raz uses mental connection to
accidentally change forsythe's mind to
associate risk with delight
her mental state begins to unravel as
elements of her past as a doctor start
to transfuse with gambling oh
no looks like hollis had a spontaneous
change in her world view
themes of guilt fear and risk are
intertwined with old-style vegas and
hospitals
resulting in raz having to gamble with
literal concepts of life and death as a
puzzle element
to proceed and in the process learns
more about forsythe's character beyond
her stern and hard exterior
but the most shining example of level
design themes and gameplay
all working symbiotically is copton's
cook-off which is
absolutely hilarious and kind of
disturbing
it's time for
the whole thing is a take on performance
anxiety it's intense race against the
clock to gather animated talking
ingredients like eggs fruits and meats
to boil in water
blend in a blender or get sliced by a
giant hatchet
all the while using the environment to
grind between cooking stations and avoid
obstacles like
giant cheese grinders or hot plates all
of which was
peppered with comical tongue-in-cheek
commercial breaks but in the end it's a
heartfelt and considerate take on a
character
struggling with eternal judgment and
unworthiness amongst his peers
you can do it next one won't be so easy
but in a continuous clashing of concepts
and design
the next level was a complete 180 from
the anxiety-induced cook-off nightmare
instead of the concentrated stress fest
of the last level this one was
wide in scope and ambitious in its
display of a fantasy reflective of the
character's mind that it takes place in
cassie is a teacher who loves big worlds
storytelling
and literature and therefore the level
itself is
big adventurous and made up of literal
books
for cassie her personal problems is that
she's had trouble letting go
and for a coping mechanism in her mind
she's created multiple versions of
herself that are
literally buried in the books she loves
cassie you gotta watch out
there's a giant uh you
out there hunting for you in order to
help
face cassie's biggest foe herself i had
to navigate a fantastical world made up
of
paper castles sail on paper made boats
hop through
literal pages and use written sentences
as my platforms
to find the other versions of herself on
the surface psychonauts 2 is shaping up
to be an engaging ambitious honed
in take on colorful three platformers
however
the most promising aspect hasn't just
been returning to its world mastering
its platforms or combat
but peeling back the layers to see
what's beneath it to take a closer look
at its characters
the depth of their struggles fears and
regrets
all of which serve as the foundation and
inspiration for the world's you traverse
and all that has left me very very eager
to see what it means for the sequel when
it launches on august 25th
if you're a fan of psychonauts consider
checking out a retrospective i did on
the first one
you can find a link to that in the
description below additionally i did a
written
version of this preview as well which
you can find on our website at
gamespot.com
which has a little bit more detail as
well as some tidbits from an interview i
did with the game's director
tim schaefer and art director lissette
teatri montgomery so again
links below all right thanks for
watching hope this was helpful to you
till next time see you later
[Music]
you